[Musique]
téléphone mais aussi caméra numérique le
portable est à toutes les sauces et
l'édition 2005 du congrès mondial de la
téléphonie mobile le prouve tous les
moyens sont donc bons pour attirer le
regard ou mythifié l'objet qui est
devenu inséparable
plus question de l'abandonner chaque
année ses fonctions augmente il devient
un véritable ordinateur aux multiples
fonctions et génère des telles
innovations et de produits dérivés
alcatel a mis au point ce système qui
permet de suivre un événement sportif en
direct sur son téléphone
grâce au système java un moyen aussi
pour chaque concurrent équipés d'un
téléphone gsm de suivre les évolutions
de son adversaire direct
aujourd'hui le téléchargement et
l'échangé de fichiers représentent la
majorité du trafic de l'internet
l'an dernier 35 millions d'européens ont
téléchargé de la musique et logiciels
des changes très simple d'emploi se
multiplient et pour cause ils sont
gratuits et en libre-service télécharger
un fichier mp3 c'est un peu voler un cd
dans un magasin le rap est l'une des
musiques les plus piratés mais tous les
secteurs sont touchés en 2003 en france
on a vendu 18 % de céder en moins alors
à quel moment franchi ton la frontière
de l'illégalité
y at il des risques
les affiches contre la loi fillon et les
stocks de pancartes se comptent par
centaines
mais pour ces lycéens ce n'est pas
suffisant au siège de la fidl le
principal syndicat lycéen
les préparatifs vont se poursuivre
jusqu'à demain tout le monde se relaie
pour en faire toujours plus on fait de
notre mieux pour que les plus de lycéens
qui viennent me soutenir et petits
faire bouger ça bouge et nous verrons
le gouvernement qui a commencé à bouger
hier françois fillon a annoncé le
retrait de sa réforme du bac à l'horaire
[Musique]
des jeunes qu'ils ressentent des
troubles de l'attention ou de la mémoire
et qui consultent de plus en plus leur
médecin car aujourd'hui au plan national
un ado de 17 ans sur cinq fumée
régulièrement du shit
des chiffres en constante augmentation
et ils sont comparables en alsace fausse
nous avons 17 % des garçons qui sont
concernés en alsace et un peu plus de 5%
défi donc vous voyez que l' usage
la consommation de cannabis d'un usage
régulier en tout cas est un phénomène
qui concerne trois fois plus les garçons
à la banque de france il faut vraiment
prendre son mal en patience pour
échanger ces derniers feront encore
plusieurs mois pour ramener vos billets
mais pour les pièces le dernier délai
c'est jeudi et vous êtes nombreux à vous
y prendre dernier moment qu'on avait on
les garde malheureusement le davinci
code un succès mondial dont l'histoire
commence au louvre à paris un éminent
conservateur est assassiné sous les yeux
de la joconde pas de témoin pas de piste
l'enquète peut commencer le principal
suspect un américain historien de l'art
poursuivi par la police française mais
innocent il se retrouve lui-même à la
poursuite du graal une course contre la
montre à travers tout paris gare
saint-lazare ambassade des états unis le
ritz et l'église saint sulpice pour 2000
euros
on peut faire la visite de tous les
lieux du livre à saint sulpice
le prêtre a dû poser un panneau pour
démêler le vrai du faux mais certains ne
le crois pas je crois qu'il ya un
certain nombre de gens qui pensent que
je fais partie du complot et que je suis
un haut dignitaire de cette secte
secrète
ronaldo se marie si ce soit
ronaldo le footballeur super mais voilà
on est david beckham you to et compagnie
d'accord et george clooney non non et
non pas de george clooney enfin en tout
cas on nous l'a pas dit mais des bateaux
plein de badauds et surtout l'ensemble
des journaux magazines web telles les
chaînes hertziennes du câble et du
satellite locales ou nationales scotché
devant les grilles du château jetons de
la classe ils ont de l'argent sorti non
pour l'argent c'est mes petites villes
et tobrouk à la saint valentin il n'y a
pas que les roses qui fleurissent dans
les rues les panneaux publicitaires se
charge de
des idées à tous ceux qui seraient en
panne d'imagination comme cette campagne
pour la lingerie qui ne laisse de marbre
ni les piétons ni les automobilistes ont
exagéré quand même parce que comme ça on
peut attraper les accidents et sinon
pour ses nus quoi on veut tellement
l'évolution de la femme
et puis en fin de compte ça ne vous dit
pas beaucoup et on se rend compte qu'on
a encore beaucoup de choses à dire et à
faire
c'est aussi l'avis d'un mystérieux
groupe de kohler qui a posé sur les
affiches des bandeaux au slogan très
explicite
c'est un peu l'anti plus bas ça marche
en tout cas on voit le message en tout
cas
laisse-moi toucher ton visage et
embrasser l'amour qui emporte comme un
ouragan
c'est avec ces quelques mots d'amour
qu'il a gagné qu'il a gagné ça sauve
visage placardée dans tout paris
bref jean michel c'est la sphère du mois
les doigts sur le clavier nous caressons
nuit tu fais vivre mon âme et ravive la
flamme jeter tant rêver au bout du
virtuel toi mon amour bien réel j'ai
envie de thé mais pour l'éternité
sa requête amoureuse habille les murs
parisiens pas moins de 100 panneaux
publicitaires une campagne d'une valeur
de 15 mille euros avec à la clé
peut-être le grand amour
les français deux fois plus que les
autres européens nous disent qu'ils sont
capables de tomber amoureux raid en
échangeant des emails et en ce jour de
la saint valentin
internet sert non seulement à trouver
l'amour mais aussi à l'entretenir sur
les écrans numériques de paris des
milliers de messages défilent depuis ce
matin on y apprend que françoise est
amoureuse que stéphanie adore fabrice et
que christophe ferait mieux de rappeler
catherine s'il est bien l'homme qu'il
prétend paix
[Musique]